من مكه مراسل مساء العربيه هاني صفيان
اهلا بك هاني نتحدث اليوم عن اكثر من عشره
ملايين مصلن ومعتمر تم تقديم الخدمات لهم
منذ بدء شهر رمضان المبارك تفضلي
نعم نادين وسهام وقد يزيد هذا العدد ايضا
ويتجاوز 11 مليون ونصف المليون مؤتمر
وزائر بعد انتهاء هذا اليوم وبعد ادائهم
لصلاه التراويح المنظر من على من اعلى سطح
مسجد الحرام نشاهده هنا في صحن المطاف عبر
كاميرا الزميل سعود العلي وهو يلتقط هذه
الصور الخاصه
لمساء العربيه والمنظر المهيب للمعتمرين
والذي خصص صحا المطاف بان يكون هو فقط
للمعتمرين سواء من ناحيه دخولهم او كذلك
خروجهم هناك ست مسارات خصصتها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين من اجل الدخول المعتمرين في هذا
الصحن وهو صحن المطاف وكذلك عبر الطوابق
الاخرى نتحدث عن اربع طوابق اضافيه
وخصصتها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين لطواف
المعتمرين هناك ايضا الجانب الاخر وهو
السعي
ذلك ايضا في الجهه الاخرى وهناك جهات من
اداره رئاسه شؤون الحرمين في قطاع التشغيل
وكذلك في قطاع الامن او امن الحج والعمره
يقومون بعمليه تنظيم ومراقبه لمتابعه سير
المعتمرين وتسهيل مهمه طوافهم وساعيهم حتى
خروجهم بسلام وامان هناك من ناحيه
التقنيات وبشكل سريع حتى لا يمضي علي
الوقت والزمن الخدمات هي خدمات تقنيه
فالمعتمر اول من يقوم به او يريد الذهاب
الى المسجد الحرام للتواصل والسعي فهو
يستطيع ان
يقوم بتحميل تطبيق له خاص وهو تطبيق نسك
او تطبيق رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين ويعرف هذا
التطبيق الى اين يتجول بوابات المتاحه له
وكذلك ايضا المناطق التي يتوجه لها بينما
ايضا المعتمرين يقومون الطواف هنا في هذه
اللقطات في جهه اخرى وزاويه اخرى وهي على
سطح المسجد الحرام هناك في الجهه الاخرى
يقوم فريق من رئاسه شؤون الحرمين واداره
التنظيف تحديدا تقوم بعمليه تنظيف سريعه
ومتكامله ولا تسبب ازدحام ايضا للمعتبرين
الذين يقومون بالسير على هذا السطح او
كذلك في الطوابق الاخرى وتتم عمليه
التنظيف المسجد الحرام كامله في وقت قياسي
وعند ساعه صفر واحده لتجاوز مدتها
الاربعين دقيقه وفق اليات وتقنيات وعمليات
تنظيف حديثه ومتطوره ووفره رئاسه الشؤون
الحرمين من اجل الحفاظ على عمليه التطهير
والتنظيف وتكون مستمره ولا ايضا ولا تعيق
حركه المؤتمرين وايضا الزوار الدخول الى
المسجد الحرام او الخروج من
فلن نشكرك على هذه المشاهد عبر عدسه
الكاميرا مشهد المهيب من الحرم المكي شكرا
جزيلا لك هاني